disclaimer ich bin weder finanz noch
steuerberater und alle in diesem video
genannten daten und fakten sind
sorgfältig recherchiert aber immer ohne
gewähr und dienen ausdrücklich nicht als
ratschlag sondern spiegeln nur meine
persönliche meinung wieder
darauf habe ich mich damit dass der
titel ist
wo soll ich anfangen seitdem ich 16 bin
träume ich davon orts und zeitunabhängig
das zu machen wonach ich mich berufen
fühlen niemals hätte ich damals gedacht
dass finanzen dabei eine große rolle
spielen für mich war geld eher etwas was
menschen automatisch verdirbt und ich
dachte so lange ich das tun kann was ich
liebe und genug zu essen habe ist geld
unwichtig wie sich herausgestellt hat
die abhängigkeit vom geld echt einen
riesigen einfluss darauf wie viel zeit
man für seine herzensprojekt hobbys
familie und freunde hat und natürlich wo
man diese zahl zu bringen kann und das
leider selbst wenn man gar nicht viel
geld braucht um glücklich zu sein
dieses video wird nicht dabei begleiten
wie ich zusammen mit einem experten im
thema finanzen eben diesem ziel näher
komme und es versucht nebenbei einen
kleinen aber bitter nötigen einblick in
die grundlagen des sparens und
investieren zu bieten für ein publikum
welches genau wie ich garantiert noch
nichts davon in der schule gehört hat
dieses video wird unterstützt von safe
disk in diesem video werde ich
offenlegen wie viele ich mit youtube
werbeeinnahmen und meinem schnittkurs
verdiene und ja das mache ich wirklich
ich werde offen legen wie und wofür ich
das geld privat ausgebe anhand dessen
zusammen mit einem finanzexperten
transparent für euch meine konnten
komplett neu strukturieren und
anschließend investments tätigen um
möglichst schnell finanziell unabhängig
zu werden ein unwirkliches ziel rente
mit 30
und da ich mir ein profi ins boot geholt
und zwar thomas von finanzfluss wir
haben vom sprecher schon weil mir
gesprochen dass du hast mal gesagt so
das ultimo ziel also für dich
finanzielle freiheit unabhängig zu sein
das heißt ich muss nicht mehr arbeiten
aber ich kann trotzdem noch arbeiten
wenn ich bock hab aber ich bin halt
keinen euro knicks mit angewiesen und
kann die sachen einfach nur machen was
mir spaß macht nicht weil ich es machen
muss jetzt stellt sich die frage wie
viel geld muss das sein was denkst du
wie viel geld brauchen würde es nun ein
monatlicher betrag der die reichen würde
total fünf netto könne also kann es
einfach durchbrechen sagt seine
monatliche netto wunsch rente gibt es
einen 3500 euro 4000 euro okay dann
erwartete rendite sagen wir mal
bleiben wir bei den fünf prozent genau
und jetzt berechnete die hier und total
er sagt hier 1,3 millionen 1,3 millionen
euro
das muss man erst mal sacken lassen aber
es gibt da etwas was das ganze deutlich
beschleunigt ganz einfach gesagt der
zinseszinseffekt wenn man monatlich zb
100 euro einfach aufs sparbuch packt und
stehen lässt während es nach 30 jahren
36.000 euro
wenn man jetzt diese 100 euro monatlich
anlegt und jedes jahr fünf prozent
zinsen oben drauf bekommt und im jahr
darauf dann wieder fünf prozent ob die
bereits gewachsene summe dann hat man
innerhalb von 30 jahren nicht 36.000
sondern sogar 83 1712 euro und 59 cent
also glatt das 2,3 fache bzw
fast 50.000 euro einfach so geschenkt
hat es mir hier eintragen welchem alter
des erreichen möchte
ok 30 dass der challenging 30 jahre und
dann bisher vorhandenes kapital das
kannst du jetzt wenn du gerade bei null
anfängt kann zum 0 1 trevor manuel
natürlich machen wir jetzt musst du ein
heutiges alter eintragen damit der
berechnen kann
wie lange die laufzeit ist hat
tatsächlich morgen geburtstag und wir 22
das heißt dass acht jahre zeit um auf
1,3 millionen euro zu bekommen das heißt
ich muss jeden monat knapp 2000 netto
wegsparen genau und die sparrate ist die
erste stellschraube an die wir jetzt
gehen werden uns die besteht aus einem
und ausgaben
ich habe wirklich ewig nachgedacht ob
ich das jetzt machen soll oder nicht
aber ich denke ehrlichkeit und
transparenz währt am längsten ich weiß
auch das ist der smart business buchwert
das jetzt nicht zu sagen und es kann zu
halten wie die meisten anderen aber ich
persönlich habe eigentlich immer relativ
wenig von der in deutschland ansässigen
mentalitäts über geld spricht man nicht
gehalten und deswegen gehe ich jetzt mal
mit dankbarem aber auch schweren herzens
voran
also basierend auf dem durchschnitt der
monate januar bis april verdiene ich im
monat trauen 30 1750 euro
foto nach steuern sind das ungefähr
19.500 euro sollte das wird natürlich
nicht immer so bleiben
es kann jeden monat vorbei sein kann es
wirklich glauben wie viel davon jetzt
genau woher kommt wird euch
wahrscheinlich überraschen aber dazu
später mehr
und da ich weiß was das für eine
unrealistische glückliche situation ist
will ich möglichst verantwortungsbewusst
mit diesem glück umgehen denn egal wie
viel man verdient wenn man wie so manch
andere youtuber alles für autos
klamotten und lifestyle raushaut wird
langfristig nicht viel davon bleiben
aber sieht das bei mir so viel besser
aus das heißt die einnahmenseite es
relativ schnell gemacht und jetzt kommt
der ausbildung apparat dass es die
ausgabenseite so mieter 750 strom
heizung und so weiter neben der miete
gehören zu den monatlichen fixkosten
noch circa 80 euro strom 17 eur 50
gez-gebühren sechs euro 60 für eine
haftpflichtversicherung 13 eur 25
hundesteuer 70 euro für abonnements wie
diesen die plus netflix amazon prime und
so weiter insgesamt habe ich 1000 62
euro fixkosten jeden monat das klingt
jetzt auf dem ersten augenblick mehr als
vernünftig im verhältnis zu meinem
einkommen aha war jetzt kommt noch essen
ja also hier sehen wir fast jeden
zweiten tag bestellt wir machen jetzt
mal im letzten monat 1230 pro monat
das heißt ungefähr 1200 für
lieferdienste und das schon krass aber
wir haben bestimmt auch für 200 euro
restaurant
1468 gut das heißt du bist insgesamt bei
2000 euro variablen ausgaben 3119
ausgaben privat jeden monat ich bin der
meinung ich sollte diese summe auf
maximal 2200 euro reduzieren aber ich
gebe also als privatperson circa 3000
euro monatlich aus und jeder cent an
einnahmen der darüber hinaus geht soll
ab sofort investiert werden sehr gut das
heißt wir wissen jetzt wie viel du
monatlich sparen kann sie hätten teilt
sich das so ein bisschen auf und dann
kannst du ungefähr sagen okay ich kann
jeden monat 15.000 auf die seite legen
also kannst du sagen okay ich mache
jetzt mal ein dauerauftrag das jeden
monat jetzt auf ein wertpapierdepot
überwiesen wird bald anfängt zu arbeiten
und dann sprechen wir darüber wie kannst
du das geld anlegen damit das halte ich
für mich arbeitet zusammen mit thomas
habe ich folgenden masterplan erstellen
circa 50.000 euro fließen aus
verschiedenen quellen auf das
geschäftskonto wie viel davon jetzt von
youtube oder meinem schnittkurs kommt
erzähle ich euch später nachdem
mitarbeiter bezahlt käufe getätigt und
die umsatzsteuer abgeführt ist bleiben
circa 33 1750 euro über von denen nach
einkommenssteuer ungefähr 19.000 euro
für mich als privatperson bleiben bevor
es jetzt an den sparauftrag und das
investieren geht sollte man normal erst
seine rücklagen bilden für angestellte
werden hier drei bis vier nettogehälter
empfohlen ich als selbstständiger muss
hier natürlich sicherheitshalber
großzügiger planen mit zwölf
monatsausgaben und dafür muss ich eben
diese bankkonten aufsetzen und ein spar
depot eröffnen ich habe noch gar nichts
mehr so wie wir müssen uns kommt an welt
neu aufsetzen
[Musik]
er musste zur postfiliale gehen
heutzutage geht s digital per app kann
man gleich direkt zu machen haben wir
auch jetzt legitimieren und antrag
abschließend klicken
ich habe jetzt also mit 22 jahren zum
ersten mal selbst ein bankkonto eröffnet
und das online die verifikation erfolgt
ebenfalls digital und nach wenigen
minuten habe ich ohne eine bank zu
betreten ein bankkonto eröffnet ihm dass
ich im folgenden einen fünfstelligen
betrag als notfall rücklage einzahlen
werde
manche minuten hat es gedauert
depoteröffnung aber banking ist nicht
das einzige thema in dem einem die
digitalisierung das leben stückchen
leichter macht denn von dem geld was man
als selbständiger aufs konto bekommt bis
zu dem was man nach ausgaben
umsatzsteuer und einkommensteuer noch
behalten darf ist es ein weiter weg von
einer seelenlosen papierkram und
langweiliger ordnerstrukturen jeder
normale mensch wahrscheinlich bis kurz
vor die abgabefrist ignoriert und
verdrängt aber das muss nicht sein mit
cfds unserem heutigen sponsor rechnungen
beziehungsweise belege einfach mobil per
app einscannen oder am pc als pdf per
drag drop in die software ziehen selbst
erkennt daraus automatisch die
rechnungsnummer den rechnungssteller den
rechnungsbetrag dann auch schnell eine
kategorie auswählen und jetzt direkt
klare strukturen toller statistiken
unsere automatisierte einnahmen
überschuss rechnung also wenn er selbst
wenn ich sage das gerade werden wollten
steuern und buchhaltung sind echt nicht
das tops dann selbstständig sein land
ist das jetzt kostenlos 14 tage ihr
müsst dafür absolut keine
zahlungsinformation angeben und könnt
komplett unverbindlich alle funktionen
ausprobieren
der link dazu ist in der video
beschreibung jetzt aber wieder zurück
zum investieren muss die ganze kohle von
sponsoring
deswegen werden das depot eröffnet was
jetzt machen müssen ist noch
daueraufträge einrichten und dann mit
dem investieren loslegen und das
investieren muss auch automatisiert sein
sonst vergisst muss nämlich und das geht
am besten per sparplan
du kannst ja erstmal also alles ist halt
wertpapierdepots und du kannst aktion
einigen etf auch immobilien aktien oder
immobilien etf sparte
was sind etf hier eine ganz grobe
erklärung im gegensatz zu einer
einzelaktie zum beispiel von tesla die
natürlich sehr schnell steigen aber auch
fallen kann setzt man hier auf hunderte
oder tausende unternehmen wenn also
eines davon extrem im kurs fällt oder
steigt fällt das beim gesamtinvestment
kaum ins gewicht aber wie profitiert man
davon man spekuliert hier darauf dass
der weltmarkt also alle unternehmen
weiterhin die
bisher um durchschnittlich sieben
prozent jährlich wächst und dadurch auch
sein erspartes was uns wirklich
interessiert ein weltweiter
anlagestrategie also was wir häufig auf
unseren kanal machen so ne 2 etf
solution das ist msc world das sind die
23 industrieländer und dann noch so
interessant hab ich mir also 30
entwicklungsländer also hier so was wir
in merching markets mit drin ja ich
würde im zweifel einfach blind vertrauen
okay das ist immer schlecht hh weil im
endeffekt muss man sich damit wohl genau
hier siehst du dann die ganzen
informationen die man sich idealerweise
anschauen sollte bevor man etf
investiert sterne sie ist war die
gewichtung um sich das ein sehr hoher
prozentsatz in den usa angelegt ist
alles gab damit danke ich mich dann
schauen wir mal dass wir jetzt alles mal
den griff kriegen das vierte von thomas
habe ich jetzt innerhalb von einer woche
meine konten optimal strukturiert
rücklagen gebildet und ein spartipp
angelegt in dem monatlich 15.000 euro in
its fließen 60 prozent davon in den msc
world 30 prozent in msc in merching
markets und 10
im eurostoxx wenn ihr wissen wollt was
ist alles genau ist checkt am besten mal
den kanal und die website finanzfluss
auf der thomas euch genau das alles
erklärt so wie wir das jetzt gemacht da
muss ich mich um gar nichts mehr kümmern
ich muss nicht aktiv irgendwelche aktien
handeln und rein und rausgehen was läuft
jetzt alles automatisch so weiter und
wenn es so weiterläuft wie bisher hab
ich tatsächlich in sechs jahren die
komplette finanzielle freiheit erreicht
und kann das schon mit 18 und 20 jahren
in rente geht natürlich nur wenn ich
will und wir wissen natürlich alle dass
dieses glück hier nicht ewig währt und
nächsten monat vorbei sein
so und jetzt die frage die natürlich die
allermeisten interessiert und da zu
setzen und alba macht hin
woher kommt denn die ganze kommt also
durch youtube werbeeinnahmen ist die
dinge die ihr vor dem video immer
überspringt kommt ca 6000 euro monatlich
rein und durch einen schnittkurs und
darf wenn ich erst am allermeisten stolz
kommen 5000 euro ein
durch ein einzelpreis von knapp unter 40
euro aber jetzt fragt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich entweder noch ein
bisschen viel
und jeder der tunnel berg video schon
gesehen hat der weiß was jetzt kommt
aber keine angst ich werde euch die zeit
natürlich möglichst konkret erzählen
produktplatzierungen und werbungen mit
ihrem und diensten nicht cool finde
kommen monatlich circa 40.000 euro rein
und seit kurzem bin ich auch auf twitter
aktiv und was die tritsch streaming
einnahmen angeht da kommt noch mal ein
extra video dazu auch was die einnahmen
meiner app die echte die decke
geschossen ehe sachen geht kommt
natürlich auch noch ein extra wieder
dazu und sogar durch die spotify namen
die ich mit meinem song der jetzt echt
250.000 teams bekommen hat da kommt auch
noch mal wieder dazu ich möchte wirklich
möglichst rasch beendet sein und das
sind insgesamt circa 50.000 euro
monatlich und dann ungefähr 16.000 euro
ausgaben monatlich und das was einst
über bleibt sind diese 33 1750 ungefähr
durchschnittlich am anfang des videos
bereits erwähnt hat
ich finde einfach er hat irgendwie so
ein bisschen anrecht darauf dass zu
erfahren natürlich muss man es nicht
sagen aber ich lasse euch ja schon an so
ziemlich allen teilen und ich bin es
wird zeit dass mal einer das hat
natürlich absicht ist bei so ziemlich
jeder zeile ich in dem video genannt
habe gesagt ungefähr oder ca und das
liegt daran weil ich es ganz einfach
noch nicht was man weiß als
selbständiger halt erst am ende des
jahres wie viel man jetzt konkret im
jahr steuern gezahlt hat und wie viel
man angenommen hat und wieviel ausgaben
mann hatte unter anderem jahresabschluss
machen meine steuerberater das tip top
aber jetzt aktuell für das laufende jahr
kann ich natürlich nur sehr sehr genau
grob geschätzt sagen der linkshänder ist
also der software für buchhaltung ist in
der video beschreibung nächste woche
kommt ein ganz verrücktes video wenn er
schon kleine hinweise und ausschnitte
daraus sehen möchtet schaut gerne mal
auf instagram vorbei da teile ich
nämlich schon immer vorab einiges aus
dem video auch zu neuen wohnung wenn er
mich auf diese leute begleiten möchte
abonniert gerne diesen kanal und dann
sehen wir uns demnächst mal wieder
macht's gut
[Musik]